[Music]
this is a really nice little uh bit of
news here a new york zoo welcomes a
newly hatched penguin whoa fostered by a
pair of gay penguin dads
wha whoa
but doesn't that [ __ ] with the the
penguin family unit yeah uh apparently
in this case it's completely fine but if
you raise the kids with two dads now
they're not gonna have any maternal um
you know things that they have mommy
issues wait are um in the penguin
species do the dads kind of do the uh
raising of the penguin child oh right
like like if they do that anyways they
both kind of have the like nurturing
instinct yeah i'm asking i have no idea
well i i mean i don't know if that's
normally what they do but these both
these penguin dads incubated the egg and
are feeding and taking care of the baby
oh the dad had the little egg in between
like you know when them when they wobble
like this yeah they carry it don't they
don't they like you mean this thing
right here yeah yeah yeah that that
thing
yeah that thing yeah when the kid goes
to sleep the dads [ __ ] start making
out and [ __ ] yeah how do they know that
the penguins are gay
yeah
dating season these two penguins bonded
so they formed the bond you could just
kind of tell so then they were like a
pair
i know when a penguin's gay
it's a partnership that's what he just
said did they do the heart you know when
two penguins guys you could just tell
kind of looks like when you know two
guys are gay
it's the exact same thing
did they do the heart shape when they do
the touch beaks have you guys seen that
isn't that a swan penguins are cute oh
that is swans oh yeah it's swans it's a
lot
no i've seen penguins do it too
let's do as the swans do yeah they're
just blocks yeah they don't have any
shape to their body yeah so they glue
close together during the breeding
season and they cared for the egg
together i wonder how many penguins are
gay in the arctic uh penguin thing at
san diego zoo i mean uh sea world isn't
there a thing where like there's like
certain animals that has like a higher
rate of like gayness i was gonna say
danish and i stopped myself because i'm
like it has to be a better word like
homosexuality yeah it's uh it's uh what
is it called naturally occurring in the
in the dolphins yeah i think mammals
right there's a school of fish that like
when the where where the school of
fishies were like when when one uh male
or female dies
to make it even
they can transition oh yeah sea horses
do that like in jurassic park
the eggs too or the
the males the yeah the dudes hold the
[ __ ] the seahorses they can they're
hermaphrodites so they can change the
where'd the egg come from do the male
penguins so what happens in this zoo is
that they don't just let any penguin
raise their own egg because some
penguins aren't good parents yeah they
could just they could just crush their
egg or [ __ ] it up so what they do is
clumsy ones what they do is they take
the eggs these are straight though they
put a fake egg
yeah i know
thank god they put a fake egg to test
how the parents take care of the egg and
if it's a good
process then they put it back they give
them like a sack of flour that's what
they should do
you know what in high school you know
how they got the [ __ ] like you have
to take care of the baby and [ __ ] right
i never did at my school but like i saw
it in shows and movies but like um they
should do that for humans
we're like if you want a kid
we'll give you a [ __ ] practice kid
you have to pass all the rules
if you can do it then you can have a kid
what do you what do you think the
protocol would be to find out if you're
if you have a kid away then the state
takes it away how about that
great idea right stay controlled
personally and just give it to two gay
penguins yeah two gay penguins they'll
probably father the human better than
what happens what happens if my dummy
baby snaps all the [ __ ] piano strings
on my piano yeah how do you do that
the dummy faces
wow you throw that dummy baby away you
throw it away you get rid of it i guess
there's a statue of limitations for
children
what what are the uh parameters you
think that make a parent qualified to
have a baby in this day and age today
don't touch your kids in a sexual way
okay that's a blanket
number one all right
good we're saying everything there don't
chuck your baby across the room okay
okay don't throw your babies
okay honestly though i mean we wouldn't
have social workers if those two were
just so obvious very true yeah very true
we gotta teach them they should just
make those rules
hey did you know
you don't want to smoke crack all night
and leave your baby
oh i didn't know that i'll stop smoking
crack thank you
are you a social worker dude that was
pretty funny gotta be like did you know
world of warcraft
call of duty all these games are fun but
when you're a parent
they're more fun
kind of want to take care of the baby so
when you're playing the game have the
baby right here if i can rock the crib
and then play don't put them in the
other room do it like this
can't do it like this yeah did you get
more tents in the game
what do you think is the appropriate uh
family income in order to have a kid
depending on where you live arkansas
twenty thousand dollars los angeles one
million dollars one million minimum to
advocate hell yeah and los angeles do
you know the average home price in la is
seven hundred [ __ ] thousand dollars
for a three bed two bat hulk the other
day i was looking for a comparison right
so in vegas let's say you look for homes
around the 400 000 range you're gonna
find some decent [ __ ] clean [ __ ] in nice
neighborhoods whatever
you i was looking for a three-bedroom
home in la all of l.a i'm talking about
from like you know long beach all the
way to the valley right 400 000. you
know what i saw a gutted [ __ ] up home
that was like
it's a fixer-upper
it was no toilets nothing it was just
it was it was an empty home that it was
abandoned for four hundred dollars it's
not even livable really not livable the
other one was a uh one bedroom in
compton
it was in a three bedroom it was just a
one bedroom in compton and then the um
the the living room looked like somebody
just like put together with plywood
it was [ __ ] up
for 400 000 bucks
so you need a million dollars in l.a to
be a good parent yeah some states you
could spend like 300 and get a brand new
house yeah arkansas this is about gay
penguins
i'm sorry you asked me the question i
had to answer like a politician i didn't
think some sort of like you know you
gotta like
show that you're responsible or know the
rules to get a driver's license i feel
like yeah parents you need something
like i think it's i think it's a little
bit wild that like just anyone at any
time could just have a kid and it's
totally like even if they have zero
resources i could be like i'm 15. you're
15. high five we're gonna be parents you
know it's like what the [ __ ] that's a
very good gay penguin it sucks for the
kid i mean because in this process with
the with the penguins it's like it's so
meticulously done they have to make sure
it's the perfect thing even if the uh
the egg gets cracked like they're right
there to like make sure it's okay yeah
but like humanity still as long as it's
been around it's just like hey you're on
your own
sorry baby
with no food well you think you think
like back in the day maybe like you know
1800s or something like that right it's
like same thing right anybody could have
a kid at any time but if you didn't have
the means then maybe they just die yeah
you know what i'm saying consider a
doctor that was in town couldn't do this
couldn't do that whatever right
um nowadays
even if you didn't have the means
there's still like you know certain
you know uh institutions or government
assistance or like you know uh health
centers or whatever that can kind of
like help you in that sense but like i'm
guessing most of that money comes from
like
you know us taxes yeah you know what i
mean so so maybe it kind of perpetuates
a little bit of that like constant like
oh anybody can at any time that's the
difference i mean back in the day like
if you live in this cobblestone area or
whatever right if you [ __ ] up your
family that's just on you you didn't
plant enough seeds or whatever during
the spring or fall you die yeah you die
but now if these two idiot 15 year olds
want to have five kids they can't take
care of them it's your burden you know
oh but you know what though not for ugly
piece of [ __ ] wants to have a kid
you know that thomas
[Laughter]
if i was poor and a female dude i'm i'm
[ __ ] i'm just gonna milk the system
every single kid you get you get like
thousands of bucks right and then you're
incentivized to stay single
because if you're a single mother you
make way more [ __ ] money but it also
destroys like the poor communities
because like
if you're if you're gonna make more
money as a single mother from the
government and you don't have to work
because you want to focus on your kids
or whatever right and then like if you
start to work then it changes your
income status
you know what i mean and then if you're
married and if you have somebody with
you now he's on the hook so it destroys
poor families in the structure and the
community because the government makes
it so damn easy to [ __ ] scam it joe's
running on the take money from single
mothers program
no if i was a single mother i [ __ ]
100 do it though because it makes more
sense like why would you want to work
at a minimum wage job when you have
three kids and not take welfare if
that's going to help you out way more
and pay you and you can live comfortable
why the [ __ ] but then there's like
finding true love and a father figure
for your children but i mean other than
that but the rules of the game are set
up for the players to play at that point
because you can find true love but then
you suffer for it that's the problem so
find true love just don't get married
that's true i guess but yeah yeah i had
friends whose uh
who's like mothers were single and then
were just dating guys for the longest
time and even though they wanted to get
married they were kind of holding off on
it because of the benefits of her
staying single yeah yeah so they just
kind of didn't do it
now these gay penguins yeah well that
kind of just makes you think like dude
how stupid is it that when when people
get all riled up and crazy over like
uh two gay dads when there's so many
other unqualified straight parents that
are just going to ruin this kid people
always got me about that yeah i don't
get the argument at all right
it's kind of like a funny order in which
people freak out about [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you